PROFESSOR: What
are we going to do?
We're going to explore only
the first Born approximation.
And the first Born
approximation corresponds
to just taking this part.
So this would be the
first Born approximation.
It corresponds to what
we were doing here.
What did we do here?
Well, we're simplifying the
second term, the integral term,
by using what the Green's
function looked like.
We simplified this term.
So all what we did
here was valuable,
except that there's
one little difference.
We-- in that Born
approximation, we
replaced the psi that
appears inside the integral
by the incident psi,
which is the psi in here.
So we will do that
now to simplify
this quantity in the so-called
first Born approximation.
When can we use it?
So, very good.
So when is the
Born approximation
a good approximation?
Well, we are throwing
away terms, in general.
When we're putting an expansion
of this form, we're saying, OK,
we can set the wave function
equal to the free part
plus the interacting part.
So we have the free part,
and it gave us this quantity.
And the interacting part
gave us the second one.
So the Born
approximation is good
when sort of the
free Hamiltonian
dominates over the perturbation.
So if a scattering center
has a finite-energy bump,
and you're sending things
with very high energy,
the Born approximation
should be very good.
It's a high-energy
approximation,
in which you are
basically saying
that inside the
integral, you can
replace the plane-incident
wave, because that dominates.
That's not the whole solution.
The whole solution then
becomes the plane integral wave
plus the scattered wave.
But the plane wave dominates
over the scattering process.
So it should be
valid in high energy.
It's better and better in
high-energy approximation.
So we have it here.
And let's, therefore,
clean it up.
So if we call this equation
"equation A," we say,
back to A. The first Born
approximation, back to A.
The first Born approximation
gives us psi of r equals
e to the i k i r.
Now we put all the-- and
this is all the arrows.
And we have here minus 1 over
4 pi, integral d cubed r prime,
e to the minus i k n dot
r prime, u of r prime,
and e to the i k i dot r prime.
All this multiplied by
e to the i k r over r.
So let's put a few vectors here.
That's it.
OK.
So it's basically
this same thing here,
but now replacing the
incident wave here.
That's the so-called
first Born approximation.
But now this is really good.
We can compare this with what we
usually called f theta of phi.
The expression of our brackets
is the scattering amplitude
f theta phi.
So here we have an answer.
f at wave number k of theta and
phi is equal to this integral.
Let's write it out.
Minus 1 over 4 pi,
integral d cubed r prime.
And now we will combine
the exponentials.
Happily, the two exponentials
depend on r prime.
So it's a difference
of exponents,
and we will call it
e to the minus i,
capital-K vector dot
r prime, u of r prime,
where this capital-K
vector is equal--
I kept the sign--
k n minus-- this time we'll
enter with a minus in that k--
k i or k s, the scattering k,
minus the incident i vector.
Remember, we defined
there, on that blackboard,
the scattered momentum
as k times the direction
of observation,
that unit vector.
So in combining these two
exponentials into a single one,
we have this
capital-K vector that
is a pretty important vector.
And now, this is a nice formula.
It kind of tells you story
that there are not many ways
to generate things
that are interesting.
Here it says that f k,
the scattering amplitude,
as a function of theta and phi,
is nothing else than a Fourier
transform of the potential
evaluated at what we would
call the transfer momentum.
So the scattering and bridges
are doing Fourier transforms
of the potential.
Pretty nice.
Pretty pictorial way
of thinking about it.
Fourier transforms
are functions of--
I think when people
look at this formula,
there's a little uneasiness,
because the angles don't
show up on the right side.
You have theta and
phi on the left,
but I don't see a theta,
nor a phi, on the right.
So I think that has to
be always clarified.
So for that, if you want to
use, really, theta and phi,
I think most people will assume
that k incident is indeed
in the z-direction.
z-direction.
So here is k incident.
And it has some length.
k scattered has the same length.
It's made by the same wave
number k without any index,
but multiplied by
the unit vector n.
As opposed to k incident,
that is the same k multiplied
by the unit z vector.
So the scattered vector is
the vector in the direction
that you're looking at.
So this is k s.
It's over here.
And therefore this vector is the
one that has the phi and theta
directions.
That is that vector.
And the vector k is k
scattered minus k initial.
So the vector k is
the transfer vector--
is the vector that takes
you from k initial to k
s, is the vector that
must be added to k initial
to give you the
scattered vector.
So this vector,
capital vector K--
it's a little cluttered here.
Let me put the z in here.
That vector is over
there, and that vector
is a complicated vector, not so
easy to express in terms of k i
and k s, because it
has a component down.
But it has an angle phi as well.
But one thing you can say about
this vector is its magnitude
is easily calculable, because
there is a triangle here
that we drew that has
k incident and k s.
And here is k.
So this has length
k, this has length k,
and this has length capital K.
The triangle with angle theta.
So if you drop a
vertical line, you
see that k is twice
this little piece, which
is little k sine theta over 2.
So that's one way that
formula on the right-hand side
has the information of theta.
It also has the
information of phi,
because you also need phi
to determine the vector k.
So this is an
approximation, but look
how powerful approximations
are, in general, in physics.
This approximation
is an approximation
for the scattering amplitude.
It-- first, it's a very nice
physical interpretation,
in terms of a Fourier
transform of potential.
Second, it gives
you answers even
in the case where the potential
is not spherically symmetric.
You remember, when potentials
were spherically symmetric,
the scattering amplitude
didn't depend on phi,
and we could use partial waves.
And that's a nice way
of solving things.
But here, at the expense
of not being exact,
we have been able to calculate
a scattering amplitude
when the potential is not
spherically symmetric.
So you manage to go very
far with approximations.
You don't get the
exact things, but you
can go into results that
are a lot more powerful.
So this is an explanation
of this formula.
And we can use this formula.
In fact, we'll do
a little example.
And these are the
things that you still
have to do a bit in
the homework as well.
Many of them are in Griffiths.
And indeed,
technically speaking,
what you need to finish
for tomorrow hinges a bit
in what I'm saying.
But the final formulas are
well written in Griffiths
explicitly, and in fact, half of
the problems are solved there.
So it shouldn't be so difficult.